for generations of chileans who've never
experienced high inflation rising prices
of food and fuel are a shock saleswoman
claudia araneda says she's never seen
anything like it
the other day i paid 12
for a tiny piece of meat and bones for
that price i used to buy a kilo of
fillet or sirloin steak i'm not joking
this is all i have biscuits a capsicum
two tins for the cat and an avocado
sixteen dollars
in the last six months inflation has
surpassed seven percent compared to the
usual three percent a year
last month the central bank raised
interest rates yet again by nine percent
which means new homeowners are
struggling to repay their loans
and to make matters significantly worse
the u.s dollar has reached a historic
high against the chilean peso surpassing
the 900 peso mark in fact experts say
that it will likely go over 1 000 pesos
in the next couple of months and this is
extremely problematic because 2 out of
every three items in the basic basket of
goods that chileans consume is imported
in u.s dollars
chile needs dollars to buy petrol and
gas which it does not produce
fuel and food have shot up most of all
mainly due to the ukraine crisis
but they're also internal factors the
previous government overheated the
economy with aggressive pandemic
subsidies
it's been followed by months of
political uncertainty over the economic
repercussions of a new constitution that
could be approved in september
unfortunately we are in a very stormy
scenario the authorities will have to
work wonders to revert this situation
the new government was elected on a
platform of ambitious social reforms and
promised tax hikes to pay for them but
given the economic scenario many
questioned this week's decision to push
ahead with it a move finance minister
mario marcel defends even though it will
further spook investors
when the state's resources are limited
the government must prioritize then the
next government or minister changes it
or science resources elsewhere in a
discretionary manner that ends up
eroding the legitimacy of the state's
public policies
whatever the reasons inflation and
uncertainty both of which have been
strangers to chile are becoming everyday
words in what was latin america's most
stable economy
lucia newman al jazeera santiago